you guys would you guys think about
getting like masks to wear for like
future conventions and stuff like that
i bet it's a better disguise
no that was a solid disguise dude no do
you want to talk about the disguise you
were thinking of okay okay okay you know
what you know what like after seeing
what happened on the second day i i call
up my mates and uh who was on like like
the the floor and like i was like can
you buy me a mask because i want to see
if like the mask works like a full like
a full face face mask right
and so um they buy me a mask i'm not
going to say what it is in case i end up
using it for future conventions right
they buy me a mask of a character yeah
that's that's all i'm going to say yeah
and so they we go to the bar afterwards
they bring me the masks and we and i try
it on in front of joey and i'm like joey
does this mask work at all can you tell
it's me and the first thing joey says is
like you ain't you ain't tricky and are
you anyone no
no because like it's like the mask like
just covers the face right why because
god's hair stands up it's just god's
hair above it like you can tell from
like if you are aware of what god's hair
looks like it's so freaking obvious i'm
like yep that's gone
yeah because like i i knew that that
wasn't gonna work because uh you know
back in uh ax 2018 2019 whichever the
last one was yeah aki and i tried to do
the same thing right but like we had
like
we didn't even have like a face mask we
had like a full like full covering the
head like balaclava style like mosques
yeah we're both wearing that we're like
yeah we're gonna get away with this
they'll never freaking know yeah and we
were walking from the hotel to the
convention which was like a two three
minute walk yeah and as soon as i got
out of the hotel someone was like hey
joey
i was just like [ __ ]
damn it
was just a perfect disguise immediately
gave off yeah so i don't think i don't
think it's gonna work that's why i was
laughing my ass off when conor was like
they'll never know it's me i didn't
expect it to work yeah i was like it'll
just buy me enough time you might as
well just add a sign that says i am
conor that trash does just like it says
i am not confident i am not gonna i'll
do that
sure we'll get a giant [ __ ] like one
of those pizza flipping sides yeah
[Laughter]
because i actually did try it on sunday
and it worked for a bit actually it
wasn't cause like people would
definitely recognize me like like as i
was walking around the convention uh
people would definitely recognize me but
it wasn't like it was like the corner
strap well what kind of wanted to do
which was it bought you enough time
that they didn't like you didn't get
stopped immediately
but i could see like uh like every like
fifth person i walked past they they did
like the double take they did like the
doubles right they would walk past and
then like something would click and then
they just like is that yeah yeah yeah or
like yeah who is that guy i i felt i
felt a disturbance in the force for a
second there but like that bought me
enough time to be like okay they've
looked around and i'm already like
like enough of the world yeah yeah so it
it definitely didn't hide my identity
but it made people like
immediately like not run up from a
not
not
distance yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i
i think like as long as you don't stop
in one place for too long then then it's
useful but but the problem with that is
that like you know if you if you have
that particular mask on for instance
then the word is going to spread so yeah
yeah yeah so the guy in that mask yeah
that's gone right and then it just
doesn't work anymore right because it's
like now they're just looking for the
guy in that mask
it's a one-trick pony yeah yeah yeah
exactly you got to get like a new mask
for like every day or like every [ __ ]
convention or something
yeah because i because i did see like a
couple of like people i knew like
youtubes and stuff who were like going
it like like cosplay yeah and stuff like
that and i'm like okay like that's smart
because you're like you're in a full
cosplay time exactly so it's not just
like covering the head type of thing so
like but like in saying that am i
bothered to get like a full on like full
body cosplay to like walk around no
speaking of cosplay though my god
genshin has like taken over this year
yeah oh my god like every third
cosplayer i saw was against yeah yeah
like because because normally like i
remember like the anime con experience
is like one or two characters would
completely take over now it was just
like the entire cast of genshin you know
there was a lot of engine i didn't
realize yeah it was that popular yeah
because i remember in like 2018 2019 i
think the the big thing at least for
people who came up to my sign it was
like nekopara characters and i think i
saw like two nickel power characters
today and i was like oh okay
was that big yeah i mean there was a lot
i mean because you know it's so easy to
cosplay right yeah and there's so many
variations so like it's it's very easy
for a lot of people to cosplay it but
yeah like
now it's just like genshin or demon
slayer or
i saw a lot of demons yeah i mean i was
expecting that i was expecting
a lot of jews kaisen as well that was
like that was like the big three though
yeah not mid because it's not me
yeah but like i i like my mates are
telling me that like the gentian line or
the line to buy ginseng merch was like
by far like the longest line yeah i
don't even know they were selling
gunshots yeah yeah yeah exactly and i'm
just like well this is the closest any
[ __ ] gentian fan is going to get to
buying actual phil real merch
but there was one part of me that was
like oh man there's like so many like
genji characters you know being
cosplaying and it's like oh yeah there's
like a new era of like cosplaying in uh
at cons but yeah the one thing where i
was like oh yeah this will never change
is people coming up to me making me sign
death notes
like oh my god i was like that that is a
piece of con culture that will probably
never go that will never that will never
go away and i'm like all right
that's
right there yeah
[ __ ] i just remembered that happened to
me as well i probably signed like 10 or
20 death notes like during this week and
i was like all right that's that's one
piece of like con culture i'm glad we'll
never go away it's like it's going to
the point where like i i know the
notebook now when i get when i get given
it right because because they they make
it like you always get like the death
note and then they make you sign it and
then they like close the cover and
they're like they're like staring at you
you know they're like ha what do you
think and i'm just like ha ha you got me
yeah the pages are very noticeable yeah
exactly so it's like i don't know like i
don't even have to like flip the cover
anymore to see what i'm saying i'm just
like yeah that's definitely are you
superstitious about it i know some
people don't sign death notes because
they're like oh what if i actually what
who i don't i met some people who don't
sign them really yeah oh ah because are
you wishing me to die or something
that's [ __ ] up
no i don't care ah i mean like i also
another thing is like there's a lot of
people that try to get get you in like
these nut strokes nowadays as well yes
that's the new like death note like
trick now yeah yeah it's like i i had a
couple of people being like oh can you
sign this for my friend he couldn't be
here because he had ligma
and i'm like this close to being like oh
i'm sorry for your friend
and i had to stop myself
yeah i think i think this guy tried it
on all three of us yeah i think i was
first and i just was like all right nice
it's like ligma okay wow
i was like come on man do you really
think that's gonna [ __ ] work come on
i must say that the dude who found that
restaurant in london which was called
secondus yeah yeah yeah yeah that was i
think that was i was like i was like all
right you deserve yeah that's like
that's like a deez nuts joke that ha ha
like had effort put into it yeah but i
respect that yeah because he he got us
like uh these like indian or i think
like uh like indian nuts or something
yeah it was like it was like a snack
that was made out of nuts so it was like
oh i got you some nuts from seconds and
i was like okay that's kind of funny
that was really it's like i'll take it
i'm like you know what i respect the
creativity i'll take that yeah
what was something like what was some
other gifts that you guys got
uh was anything that stood out oh there
was one actually uh we got it yesterday
but there was uh this guy this artist
guy who gave us this like poster and
he's like a mecca artist right and he
made this like maybe it's on the screen
maybe it's on screen i don't know but
like he made this uh like trash taste
mecca essentially oh my god yeah and
it's like full on like i mean
it looked freaking amazing it was like
kind of a cross between a gundam and an
ava type of thing but it was like it had
like the trash taste purple on it and it
looked really freaking cool and it was
like yeah i did it in two days and i was
like
what the hell
i wish i could do that
it was pretty nice i really wanted to
give it to alan because i know he's like
a massive make-ahead yeah yeah so i've
like held on to it so i'll give it to
i'll give it to alan that's really good
but um yeah like yeah there was just
like so many cool like just i don't know
really like talented people like a girl
gave me like a ring that she had like
made as well
yeah and uh yeah i don't know it's like
it's it's you know obviously like you
know pieces of fan on stuff like that is
like amazing as well and like we've kept
all of it obviously but um yeah i got
like a custom pokemon card for mine and
cindy's wedding it was like oh really
just like proper metal and everything i
was like that was pretty [ __ ] cool
that was one of the coolest gifts i've
ever had
i remember there was a guy who came to
my signing on the friday and he made me
sign uh like a hollow yu-gi-oh card and
i was like oh that's really cool i
haven't seen that in a long time yeah he
came back on the sunday to give me the
card oh like like
in film like this oh [ __ ] and i was just
like it's like yeah i like scoured all
over the con to like find her for you
yeah and it like came back on the sunday
it's like give it to me and i was just
like you the g bro
you're the g
give me a limited edition first
charizard please
like one did you
did you get someone did you get a
masterpiece uh no she said yeah the guy
i was really disappointed he brought out
a copy of masterpiece right uh which is
like the hand type yeah
um like it was like the full dojin
colored
yeah and uh i was like oh my god and i
was like he said yeah he's shining for
me and i'm like can i have it and he was
like no
and i was like i was like hey i gotta
shoot my shot yeah it's like oh this
this you got this for me yeah yeah it
was like a giant [ __ ] i was like i was
joking with him like you got this for me
right and he was like no and i'm like i
think you got it for me
this poor guy behind so we had like
obviously you have like a handler at a
con basically the handler's job is to
just kind of get you to where you need
to go and also help with the signings
kind of help with the flow yeah and uh
he was like this normal british dude who
just like he was talking about football
and stuff and i pretended like i
understood what was going on and um
i i take out this masterpiece to sign it
and i just open it up and i'm like nice
nice and he's like whoa
whoa i'm like oh yeah this is not normal
this is not a normal thing to open and
just admire right now
and so i closed it and i was oh he was
like wow that was that was intense when
i was like oh yeah yeah yeah
right here
no i i totally just like bought into it
because like my handler who was next to
me she was just like oh yeah you've like
signed some pretty weird things and i'm
like you haven't seen anything yet and
then literally as i said that some dude
was like can i get you to sign something
that's like very questionable and i was
like all right here we go and he pulls
out like a sasuke x naruto like yowie
dose i signed that as well and he was
like and he was like and i was like
where do you want me to sign like on the
cover and stuff like that and he's like
no open it up and find the most [ __ ]
up page to sign it on and i was like i
don't want to open this in front of my
handler being like oh i wonder where's
the most [ __ ] up scene
and then i i did find the most [ __ ] up
scene and i was like all right i'll go
right there and she was just like i'm
not no judging you know what if this is
these are your fans i guess you know and
i was like
yeah
[Laughter]
but like i had a similar experience uh
because okay we've talked a lot about
mcm i would say like the signing
experience was like the smoothest
signing experience i've ever had yeah
definitely at any convention like they
had this [ __ ] on lockdown like it was
like in and out in and out you know take
your stuff they gave us like a post note
of like what they wanted us to sign what
the what the person's name was it was
like excellent it was so streamlined
yeah it was so streamlined uh i remember
the first one the first sus one that i
got was uh it was a manga called like i
think like dick fight island or
something yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i think i remember that yeah
it was dick fight island and i was just
like oh what's this and he goes he was
like oh sydney recommended it and i was
just like that sounds like sydney
caution and he just goes off on like he
just starts going off on like the entire
synopsis right of dick fight island
which is apparently just a bunch of
dudes on an island and they fight with
their dicks that's what i'm guessing is
it but he goes into it in like such
graphic detail right and so i'm like
yeah that sounds like a really really
interesting story i signed it he goes
away we had like a little five minute
breather and my handler goes to me
so what do you do
[Laughter]
it's a long story
like i'm like how do i how do i explain
this you know you should have just been
like yes i'm the author of dick fight
island
oh you know what actually i got someone
came out to me who was like uh this is a
reference i guess to anyone who has
watched this episode of trash taste he
was like oh
man i love your work and then he just
gives me a copy of goblin slow
and i was like yeah yeah yeah and he was
like oh can you sign it and i was like
yeah dude let's do it
sign the goblin slayer oh my god oh yeah
oh god that was interesting yeah i mean
it was a lot of
normal things everyone's like bro
everyone thinks that like they're gonna
hand you the weirdest thing they're like
oh oh i'm gonna show you something
really out there yeah and it's it's like
all right
i've sounded like everything and i love
how it's those people who are always
like oh i'm sorry you're probably you've
never signed anything this weird and i'm
just like
i have no idea
this is baby mode right it's baby yeah